you
hi everyone is Jerry man chest calm and
I just got paired up playing now a 3-2
game all right let's try and stay ahead
on the clock okay maybe maybe we could
treat the clock as 10 is the new zero
maybe we could start something like that
treat the 10-second mark is if it's zero
all right so we have the light squared
Bishop s' opposing each other indirectly
right now I'm going to look for a d5
break this could enter a hedgehog
structure with the DC pawn exchange I'm
fine with this light square Bishop
exchange I'm gonna look for a setup
where my queen eventually is played into
f3
I'm gonna play a 3 B 3 Bishop b2 f4
Queen f3 in some order quite sure is
black thinking about a d5 strike c6 is
maybe a bit a bit tender d5 right away
Queen a4 so I I'm expecting a castles
and you know what maybe maybe I go for
efore let's see yeah maybe maybe I go
for this bond over the d5 square yeah
let's try that I mean I can still try
for f4 and Queen f3 let's get this move
in first she's probably going to be a
target you know let's get these moves in
b3 Bishop b2 before there's some
pressure on my pond and even the knight
on c3 so ensuing moves after the Bishop
is on B to f4 Queen f3 is played I could
think about g4 and g4 g5 and then maybe
there's something exciting here
happening on g7 with the knight being
kicked so probably get this in right now
f4 let's try it
maybe my Knights challenged right away
Knight c6 now so let's get Queen f3
my knight is unprotected with this last
move but I don't think it could be taken
advantage of b5 I have a ton of pieces
on that so maybe now g4 g5 this strike
with e5 after the g4 move to try and
grant access to the e5 square with a
knight that does give up the d5 square +
f5 square if my knight is pressurized
probably just rotated e1 maybe even if
it isn't maybe if it doesn't even have
pressure on it I have some concern about
a b5 sacrifice as soon as my rook is not
on the a file is really coming to life
here hmm maybe I keep him here although
I don't like entering complications with
an unprotected piece here
a4 is probably not too good because of
the pressure on b3 I'd like to get a
four in any for Knight c5 rook rook to
d1 should my neck get kicked it's going
to go in to f5 and then maybe I'll have
Knight d5 here my queen will defend b3
laterally well let's actually let's
let's not get too crazy
let's get another piece working if this
move happens I mean I'll be taking with
this Knight I still have my knight on c3
defending a2 and I could follow up with
a four okay so now there's not really so
much of a idea with that let's let's go
for G 4G 4G v h4 h5 and I'll just grab
some keen side space let's see what
black does in the meantime whether the
boo
whether the pawn is on g3 or G for my
King is equally accessible or a long
term but let's start with a kick yeah
let's let's rock the knight back and now
I might want to take a moment out to
address this possibility of e5 mmm no no
no II five right now ninety five hits
let's let's grab some space I could look
for h 5 h h5 g 6 undermining the e6 pawn
they may need to do this but that will
print this up this diagonal I might have
something really quick like Knight f5
that actually might be quite good no a
Knight d5 although I'd really like to
have a knight on age six or something
let's see what black comes up with I
mean I could after my h1 is exchanged I
could like looked at playing the h-file
Queen h3 rook h1 Queen g4 is uh I think
a pretty decent forward move putting
pressure on e6 ok h4 Bishop g7 h6 or
just capture 95 or would I really like
to have my knight on g6 if I could get
him here that'd be nice under a minute
or about a minute now f5
maybe f5 it gives up 95 but you can't
have it all can you let's try and open
up the F file I'm giving black 1 very
good square and they have now one very
good piece yeah 95 Queen h3 actually
let's keep pressure on this pawn also
maybe I could think about doubling on
the F file I'm reminded of a game that
has just played in the rapid World Chess
Championships between the Ivanchuk on
the white end and raja baath ok so this
cannot be good 95 right away right yeah
let's hit that with tempo here I'm
expecting Queen b7 at least stating
opposite maybe this was too quick and I
know Queen b7 seems like the only way to
keep pressure on the white position and
the take here soon because it could be
challenged to after pawn takes there's
Knight c7 to have something better I
wonder if I should take with the piece
they takes f5 that way there's no Knight
c7 to challenge this strong guy hmm pawn
takes my Knights and a pin b5 is hitting
soon huh
um yeah I'm gonna do this on Knight c7
maybe I play Knight FF 3 challenging
this Knight and reinforcing d5 try to
put pressure on have seven really soon
hmm
let's do this challenging their night
I'm not really great fan of retreating
like this but there's maybe even tricks
with rook c2 at some stage they're under
15 seconds trying to keep the pressure
on hoof sacrifice alright things are
heating up what to do here let's back up
my Brooks gonna be unprotected I need to
defend my second rank my Knights in a
pin I need to get out of that you take
here they're not playing with their
Bishop just yet um this seems like a
good start I think now my Knights not in
a pin so that's that's nice and probably
just reinforced that I think this is
important to reinforce here and probably
take maybe not so fast yeah let's take
and push if I h5 yeah actually aged
eight I'm just seeing right now I have
h8 ideas Brooksie to check King f1 a
little scary here for sure I can still
play rook d2 o trades I'm welcome to
maybe I could have played King takes
rook
I have e1 covered hmm let's take once
Queen e6 this has to be good
Queen trade don't have to take just yet
they're in a pin King position that's
just helping me know here avoiding rook
a3 with check now we're gonna take and
get to this this is the new seventh rank
rook check and then 95 No
he's pinned rook here get behind the
pawns let's improve like this yeah I
could do that
oh let's see let's just go here and I
like a block with the rook check Knight
d4 let's get here hitting the pawn and
threaten you to kick the King back let's
do this
and we're gonna just stop the pawn from
moving anymore rook here maybe
although Knight check there's no
stalemates because of these pawns here I
think I could invade with my King King
here and then rook here may threat
threatening the pawn no that's actually
going to be me they missed that they
were in a serious time pressure I tried
to stay ahead I think I did a bit more
decent a job on the clock this time
around but interesting game before I
have a look at it with stockfish what
can I really add what what kind of
thoughts of my own can I put into this
yeah I referenced that right around this
point I wanted to go for III and f4 but
I think this is more common when this
pond has already committed to d6 I felt
that if I was to go for e3 here instead
of E for that d5 would just be good and
yeah it probably would be quite good and
I don't think I would I would have
anything but regret of giving up my
light-square bishop and having my king
vulnerable on the light squares here hmm
yeah anything more I felt that d5 later
much later on when things heated up the
d5 advanced by black really helped me
because my knight on f3 was then free
yeah it's certainly getting very sharp
here maybe some things were missed right
around this point for both of us but
yeah this is an interesting point here
you know giving up this strong e5 square
you know white wants one thing white
wants to have the physician open up the
F file I open up and it's it's just one
of those I I don't know give-and-take
situations you have to give something up
in order to get something so with f5 I'm
giving up a five in order to get the F
file opening up Queen h3 maybe this
wasn't so correct Queen h3 I mean I
guess it turned out outright much
further down Queenie six happened with
check and then that's when I started to
really feel comfortable she's just a
tremendous piece on that square but
that's getting a bit ahead of myself
here
Queen h3 it seems sensible I guess just
putting pressure on the e6 which is at
this point it's hit twice defended one
so now let's hit three times defended
once and it will be collapsing and as a
result I will get the d5 square I've
given up a five but this pressure on e6
grants me the d5 square in a couple
moves and this must be better for white
but you know I wonder instead of Knight
c7 or even instead of the sacrifice
maybe this was just to you know how
about just b5 not giving in not giving
up the material so easily what about b5
here that'll be the other one to look
into just not giving up the material so
easily I could crash through here not
quite though he's still in the pin and
my King is quite vulnerable yeah I think
maybe I'm worse right here and they may
be panicked a bit much
yeah maybe they panicked a little bit
here investing this material or they
didn't see the idea of just blocking
retreating here to defend the
second-ranked and getting out of the
line of fire yeah probably probably b5
I'm thinking you know b5 pressure on c4
now and I'm still having to work out of
this pin yeah I think black is actually
better here with the b5 advance but
we'll have to confirm this with a
computer so give me a minute I'll bring
it up and we'll see what we can take
away from this one okay let's see what
we could take away from this one just
getting past the opening here we pretty
much following theory for these first 10
moves or so hmm
castles okay suggested Queen see it is
another I guess to quickly get on that
light square diagonal you four let me
let me test this III move out
does d5 hit certainly something is given
up doesn't like III you're really just
throwing your advantage away calls for
Queen c7 but I imagine d5 is good to
something off with that takes takes oh
ok so lock has to take a little bit of
care with playing d5 right away you know
this III move is allowing Queen f3 with
or without that f4 move it opens up
Queen f3 idea okay so then I could look
to play against an isolated pawn at
least if I want to go for that takes
Queen takes Queen take seat takes and
then rip deep route to d1 yeah this
would be nice
okay so d5 quite often a liberating move
the black end in what's like a Sicilian
here maybe not so fast in this case
after e3 but you know there is still
Queen c7 the e3 is the wrong idea
Queen c7 first and after b3 now you
could hit with d5 how is this a little
different oh I can't take right away
because of the night being unprotected
okay Queen c7 right away maybe even this
with an a6 b5 going for something like
that really quick
interesting okay so I didn't go for III
at the end there instead efore placing a
grip over D 5 D 6 D 3 so just a slight
pull on the white end I have 4 let's go
for a G for right away like Queen f3
okay
okay let's hold on for a moment here
because with this next move it's a point
8 advantage I certainly have to give it
some time to think but you know there's
something a little bit off with this
last move it's calling for Knight c5
Knight c5 may be looking for some
pressure immediately on e4 rook a to d1
h 6mm tough to say y h6 right here on g4
9 F to d7 hmm okay well you know here's
another thing I could point out is that
as soon as this Knight is here I mean
where did he end up going when g4 g5 hit
he played to e8 so maybe having this
knight here has this as a new
possibility something that something to
consider don't know that it's necessary
right away though I don't know the the
timing of this move hmm it's um
this is a position where I'm finding
it's just much easier to play on the
wide end you know the black is they have
this Hedgehog structure but I have the
brakes under control at this point B 5
and d5 and I don't see how black and
it's not it completely clear to me how
black goes forward and improves their
position whereas you know it's pretty
straight forward
this idea of g4 g5 h4 h5 and trying to
attack the black king yeah and it's you
know evaluation wise it's saying it's
better for why
but it's also a case where it's a bit
easier to play on the white end let's
get the rook in there and maybe spent a
bit too much time worrying of this b5
break and the pressure on a two that's
pretty much no issue for me now
even you no no no it's you now as soon
as they were committed to c8 now it does
call for g4 g5 and it's already plus two
and I probably had something much more
convincing so mm-hmm
bishop f8 natural but I'm just not
working out here it likes g6 and even
this is tending towards upon advantage
g6 g5 ok ok instead of retreating being
in a position to move forward and reply
to g5 but even so I mean we're seeing it
here given some time it's climbing the
advantage here after should the night
end up on g5 excuse me h5 instead of EA
we have Queen g4 night c5 and still f5
is hitting let's actually test something
out suppose the night does not yet
commit to c5 and still prepares to me F
F I've moved with Knight to e5 let's say
mmm tough to find a passing them
actually how about this oh ok there's
just some direct sacrifice happening the
Queen takes e6 King f8 and now f5 oh ho
ho man ok yeah sure and you know it's
not it's you're giving up a minor piece
for 2 pounds but it's more than that
it's the square that's given up d5 and
that's that's too much got the F file
opening up every every white piece is
now attacking stranded night offside
Queen one might say as soon as this
Knight plugs up the d5 square okay so
interesting to just be aware also of a
piece sacrifice on e6 ok
g5 night back how could I have done
better
instead of h4 it doesn't like h4 likes
immediate pressure on e6 Queen h3 or
even g4 I imagine don't know what the
big difference is this seems more
natural Queen h3 not the most more
natural but maybe see that if the pawn
has already played to h4 so you're just
not uh you're not obstructing your H
pawn from contributing to an attack at
some stage mm-hmm I don't know if I'll
be able to figure that out but played h4
not losing the advantage but not the at
the best no f5 Queen h3 okay Knight d5
right away it likes it's tending towards
+3 now h5 okay we're probably going to
have a shift here yupper no the capture
on f5 is not correct oh you know only
later in the game did I start to realize
I have the possibility of playing Queen
to h8 in connection with my b2 bishop
maybe I should have already been
considering that as soon as my Queen was
on h3 hmm you know how can i maybe steer
clear of doing a move like this in the
future what I am what I am doing is
placing myself in a pin that's one
reason to maybe shy away from this
natural capture and another thing is to
maybe not be so fixated on material you
know I'm trying to regain the material
here in a way right
they took my pawn I want to take back
but maybe that's just unnecessary huh +4
now given some time with this h5 move
yeah my Knights not in a pin and even if
they grab another pawn this is just
collapsing with captures and let's see
the fantastic mate yep make 14
Maur it's already feeling like there
might be some queen h8 move as a start
but yeah let me back up for a moment
because I think at this stage black
would realize you know I need some
seventh ranked defense let's take with
my panel on my queen to defend but an in
comes Knight to e6 and just every piece
of whites is doing something good
computer called for Knight g6 it's to
recapture but then it gives up f5 too
much a knight on d5 n f5 oh boy ok so I
went with the natural and not not good
it's really should get out of that frame
of mind and get on with this advance
here and you know what let me backtrack
it a little bit because now I can make
maybe a bit more sense of Queen h3
immediately without playing h4 hmm maybe
maybe that's still there's some ideas of
attacking on the h-file I wonder about
rook f5 and our f5 and then rook f4 to
h4 stuff I don't know still a little bit
of a mystery why it's a suggesting Queen
h3 here okay anyhow I recaptured with
the pond and this is where I threw away
my advantage
just that one move Knight c7 isn't it at
this point I was considering well what
about b5 that's not working because if
takes takes and then what oh man 96 Wow
sharp stuff takes Queen takes and then
Knight f7 has to be played oh yeah
King has to defend the bishop let's say
King here the Knights now in a pin h5 oh
man she's she's just a tremendous piece
on e6 isn't she coordinated well with
the dark square Bishop having the Queen
on a light square controlling ton of
light squares and he's around
to cut the King off or at least pin a
piece that's sharp
96 shot not even taking a piece so
another I don't know another variation
where we're seeing 96 happens and in
this case it isn't even taking a piece
it's just incredibly disruptive the the
coordination of both Queen and night on
this square mm-hmm these are things that
will help me to remember these tactics
in future games - yeah
95 96 hitting even when there isn't a
pond there okay 97 that's pretty natural
to pile up on that pinch piece I played
Knight f3 takes rook takes and now b5
oh yeah that's right at this point it
was b5 okay yeah they went in for this
and it's just not working I guess this
is best b5 break rook after D 1 Knight
f3 hmm I think this is more natural to
take here but actually that's a problem
because I'm threatening here on d8
Knight takes Queen takes and now getting
out of the pin mmm okay so evaluation
wise it likes white but it's much more
scary for sure
a naked King here no no pawn protection
hmm I mean I have control over the light
squares and uh nearly as convincing is
that an immediate age five instead of
about capturing a five okay well they
got two into maybe they got two a little
bit too scared around here thinking that
they needed to invest some material but
oh they could have they could have gone
for that b5 anything slipped from here F
takes G
X is better just trying to consolidate
still plus 2h five now yeah this is too
much no that likes night takes better
only upon advantage rook takes d4 Knight
takes d4 Queen e7 mm-hm pressure on g5
maybe Queenie for stuff still something
for white but something was definitely
lost and yeah takes pawn takes and then
after Queen to e6 that's gonna be it
it's too active it's only giving it as a
plus plus one Queen f7 yes it's much
easier to play for white for sure you
know what I was helped out with this
last move I said it during the game does
this check I'm just improving my King
position the rook should really stay
here this takes takes and then calling
for rook b2 and I guess then look to
push the a pawn my King is cut off yeah
this would have been better resistance
because right now he I just kind of view
this position as the Queen's already off
the board and you know this would just
be helpful
she better just keep the King cut off so
I already felt like it was a much easier
to play as soon as the rook check
happened and this is only helping me
further likes Queenie for keeping the
Queen's on the board no that wouldn't
have it's not my style at that point
just looking to simplify a bit and I
don't think that anything was spoiled
from here just as mentioned during the
game this situation here as soon as you
construct it with the knight didn't ruck
the king is in stalemate so I mean if
these two pawns weren't around there's
ideas of some
Chua with the rook you know in some
cases if you taking the rook then it's a
stalemate position but yeah there's
blacks far away far away from having
that ID in mind because of the a and B
pawns still present and yeah that's
gonna pretty much do it what's best here
to give a check but I'm picking up the
pawn and then I could move the King out
of the way and start thinking about
pushing the Jeep on okay
yeah interesting game certainly this six
square the coordination of both queen
and night on a-z six square quite
interesting landing in some cases with
the capture of a pond or even without
the capture of upon the Queen having
Queen one day residing on that e6 square
quite powerful some cases alright anyhow
interesting game as usual feel free to
leave any feedback in the comment
section below to this video and as usual
I hope you got something out of it
that's all for now
take care